(pop music)
- [Man] When a bag is made from
a billboard it has a story.
It's creative, it's bold.
Every bag is giving back
and it's being eco-friendly.
(pop music)
I was working in
advertising and I saw that
all the billboards that were going up
in essence were going to the landfill.
Most people don't know that
billboards are made of vinyl
and it can be turned into something else.
And so, I thought, “Let's create a business that's
solely based on billboards.”
(gentle music)
On any given month, we get close to around
10,000 pounds of billboards
that we turn into product.
Once that billboard
goes up, it's usually up
for a period of about four weeks
is what a typical campaign
is on the street for.
(gentle music)
It's then shipped to our facility here.
We sort it, we cut it, and
send it to the manufacturer
where they do the final sewing
and cleaning of the product.
(gentle music)
- [Man] We're able to
take a billboard that had
one purpose
and then reuse it to make something else.
(gentle music)
My brother and myself
are both huge surfers.
And we kind of felt like
the surfing community
loves bright colors.
And billboard vinyl is
actually very durable.
(gentle music)
It's a thick material.
It's waterproof, it's mildew proof.
So, it's actually the perfect material for
a surfboard bag.
After that we expanded into backpacks,
duffle bags, wallets.
- [Alec] Fanny packs, hip packs,
snowboard bags.
Every product's different.
Every product's one of a kind.
Each piece that we make
is unlike anything before it.
(gentle music)
Our playground for all of this
is based in the environment.
Whether it's the mountains, the rivers,
the ocean, it's something
that we, in essence
have a responsibility
to maintain and sustain.
(gentle music)